shawnee гри ярославу чого про команду і
таке око положення законопроект
добром ще кольорів коду не верховну раду
України
йди на вашу думу законопроект її
чи фарбовані ви їдете на сьогоднішній так
ні ми знаємо верховної ради України під
вони 3 законопроекти видно вид 1
далі особливий депутат окей не
піддавався можна назвати їх
диференціації законопроект калітника за
законопроект
яценюка та законопроект балу і я розряду
теллер 16 всі законопроекти можна
однозначно сказати ще партію
законопроект законопроект про цей
вид калетника венної пише про вид я
думав годині стандарті вище її почту і
ліквіду я європейським стандартам святі та
швидкість за розвивати пошук
університетах але крутий через не стати
цим законом можна грати повернуть його
наприклад про законопроект річки вас
Тетяни до
у законі балоги і так звана
старить агенція нехай його почти в серпні у
світи
он вони б то буду контролювати
видавати ліцензії контролю вати край
дотації університеті і хто буде якийсь
конкурс не основі даватиму людей акі
може тут його піцу організації ціль
роботи
але ми не можемо за розповісти і на ці
зовсім музика на проекті я все-таки досі
що вона може бути
ректор та проректор в курсі університету
даному пляшки комісії але я думаю що
ціни про на я який я хотів би сказати
що я навпаки ректора та проректора
які вид поїдає засвіту університету
вміння знайди джгути активними учасниками
так комісій я в законопроекті калетника
там саме що при атаках
з творить і храм пекельну роду та й
конкретно виписаний
процедура все люблять все
вибір не на всіх реван їх засадах може
будете комісії та
і думаєш і місяця буду тебе означають і
контролю вати та держава prada сильну
комісії коли збору часто проводять
цього ти і ліцензії і наводять їх до
детонації університеті так я помер би
сказати і про, наприклад, право стандарти
про святі лики пропонують ці
законопроекти я думаю що він не про
лякаючого історія чортовому світі
університеті
законопроекті балоги я шо шкіри вийшли
початкові витрати
сто років та свої стандарти the disco жити
у нас наприклад туїм наприклад
спеціаліста з першої спеціальності
математика 1 норма його начальник буду і
стає вага 70 грам чистого та вінчі
в університеті 200 води там на тремейн
життя стандарти для перетікання хафель сил
я думаю з дупи ви не but i нормою
acquia закладення пішому законі versiv
однакові вже наповнення я думав не
будуть всі тут не в університетах
менеджери голод та університети та звучали
вони б хату таких різних можна сказати
статей
річки на вигляд побачить за 1 с у приватних
паперів до вищого світла і вона клімату я
крутив би сказати ще наш університет
також туди свої позиції я думаю
олов'яні пукан євро хова не я але я
думаю вони будуть гріхів вони в ціль
законопроект але стрибати такі про
позицією від academy але кави та йди по
мене ти на академічну ступай
доступні щоб вигравати і про вас тут
інтела супного кури студенти наводяться
зубного університету when she
університет спразі виникає при мені на
точності регулювання цех перекладаємо та
при руку на них болонського процесу
мобільності студентів також натякає
харчування верхні повіки на захід а вчора
часу на кордоні катували так я б
хотів би загорнути його все-таки плити на
європейський термінів джанні парності
спочатку я поспішав жовтий для вище
початкових заплатив за вашими мовчання
польша посміхнеться та зможу
сконцентруватися
у віри срубає і таким місяцем для
підготовки
професорського датського складу для торта
місяця застрелилася студента вже
тобто підготовленим і дату волосся так
на навчальний процес
крім того ми давали пропозицій так вже
про фінансово не овочі спочатку заплатив
так я представляю регіональний
університет я думаю що б сказала
потрібно в законі стрибає свити
записати show my story міс avery
реальний бюджет та мої права також у нас
його ти університети, бо кожен
регіон хоче matiz епатажний університет
у нас яскравий держав університету вин не
закладення статті фінансування з
регіонального бюджету цьому я перегону
меншу закон калетника борошно і так
детально його парі гляну тайвін
вид в'янучи за раз знайдеш таким можна
сказати конкретним завданням деякі стоять
перед просто